final fantasy 15 is getting a season
pass no surprise there but now we know
more about what's included I'm Tony and
this GameSpot news update comes with a
bonus the season pass includes six DLC
packs the first is a booster pack that
will give you more powerful weapons in
the game
the second is an original episode that
focuses on noctis's friend gladiolus
third is a holiday item pack fingers
cross for Santa Claus suits for the
party the fourth and fifth packs are
episodes focusing on Ignace and Prompto
respectively and the final is an
expansion pack that will give you quote
a completely new way to play Final
Fantasy 15 perhaps that's referring to
the games VR experience Final Fantasy 15
comes to ps4 and Xbox one on September
30th the season pass is included in the
digital premium edition of the game
priced at 85 bucks on PSN the pass was
originally sold separately for 25 bucks
but the listing has since disappeared to
keep up with all the latest from the
world of final fantasy stick with
GameSpot
you